Making a movie isn’t exactly cheap.
Sometime hundreds of millions of dollars are
required just to produce it, with a lot more
added for marketing costs.
Because of this, studios are always looking
for ways to get a little help financially.
One of the most popular methods to accomplish
this is incorporating product placement within
a film.
This is when corporations strike a deal with
the filmmakers to place their products prominently
on screen, offering money to aid with the
budget.
There is a place for this practice, but sometimes
it causes more trouble than it’s worth.
Here are 10 horrible instances of product
placement in movies.
Captain America: Civil War
One of the most thrilling action sequences
in this MCU installment was the chase involving
Bucky Barnes, Black Panther, and Captain America.
The three superheroes outran moving cars during
the scene, and Audi wanted to get in on all
the fun.
A longtime partner of the MCU, the car manufacturer
produced a television spot to tie into the
film’s release, showcasing a family driving
in an Audi vehicle that’s caught in between
all the excitement.
Steve Rogers is about as American as you can
get, so seeing him pimp out for German luxury
vehicles is a bit jarring.
Avengers: Age of Ultron
In the buildup to this highly anticipated
sequel, Samsung got to premiere an Age of
Ultron trailer on their YouTube channel, so
it wasn’t any surprise that the tech company
got some screen time in the actual film.
Black Widow using a Samsung tablet to examine
data about Loki’s scepter is one thing,
but the brief shot of a Samsung store – complete
with an advertisement for the Galaxy smart
phone in the frame – was a bit much and
seemed like a commercial in the midst of all
the action.
There wasn’t any real need for it to be
a Samsung store, and it was arguably a little
distracting.
Star Trek
The scene where young James Kirk steals his
stepfather’s car was the perfect introduction
to the charming rogue of a protagonist.
There was just one detail that didn’t sit
well with fans.
As Kirk speeds down the road, he gets a call
from his angry stepfather on a Nokia cell
phone that’s mounted in the vehicle.
It pulls someone out of the futuristic movie
to see a modern day product, and the familiar
Nokia ringtone just sealed the deal.
The same could be said about Uhura ordering
a “Budweiser classic” at a bar.
In a sci-fi movie, you have the creative leeway
to make your own products, and directors should
take advantage of that.
I, Robot
Will Smith’s character had to drive around
in something in this sci-fi thriller, so the
Audi concept car that had nine minutes of
screen time was understandable.
What moviegoers and fans of the source material
couldn’t get over were the out-of-place
Converse commercials, in which Smith happily
boasts about his “vintage 2004” pair of
All-Stars.
As we learned from Morgan Freeman in The Shawshank
Redemption, we don’t often look at another
man’s shoes, so drawing constant attention
to Smith’s footwear earned numerous eye
rolls.
Why would a character so far in the future
be sporting these old school kicks?
Jack and Jill
Adam Sandler is notorious for product placement,
but Jack and Jill takes the cake for the worst
instance in his career.
Sandler conveniently plays an ad executive,
so the opportunities for some corporate sponsorship
were aplenty.
Everything from Coca-Cola to Pepto Bismol
to Sony computers appear throughout the film,
and the crux of the narrative is getting Al
Pacino to star in a Dunkin Donuts commercial.
Perhaps the most egregious illustration of
product placement is Royal Caribbean, when
the movie stops to showcase all the illustrious
features of a cruise ship.
Even Sandler’s biggest fans had to be put
off by this one.
Jurassic World
Colin Trevorrow’s highly popular sequel
took a joking swipe at modern sponsorship
by saying the Indominus rex should be brought
to you by Verizon.
While this bit of satire was humorous, it
unfortunately wasn’t present through the
rest of the film.
Part of Trevorrow’s approach was to embrace
product placement, but seeing the logos of
Beats by Dre, Verizon, and Mercedes-Benz stripped
away the awe and wonder of seeing dinosaurs
come back to life.
Yes, in the real world, this is probably how
it would go, but it just doesn’t sit right
when a blockbuster film is promoting so many
well-known brands.
Transformers
The ultra successful Transformers franchise
grosses billions of dollars worldwide each
time out, so companies are always eager to
have their product associated with the films.
When Michael Bay was working on the first
film, GM offered him $3 million to have their
cars serve as the robots in disguise, and
Bay happily took the money.
Each Transformer models their appearance after
a GM vehicle, including Bumblebee upgrading
his Camaro.
They even used GM’s rival – Ford – to
play the Decepticons, highlighting the classic
Chevy vs. Ford debate in a tentpole film.
Obviously, cars were needed to make a Transformers
film, but this reads as selling out, no?
Skyfall
The granddaddy of product placement, James
Bond has been selling products since the Sean
Connery days.
In the 50+ years since 007 first graced the
big screen, he’s driven Aston Martins and
worn Omega watches.
Perhaps the oddest bit of product placement
came in Skyfall, the first film in which Heineken
paid $45 million to be Bond’s favorite beverage.
It’s quite a departure from his normal martini,
and the trademark green bottle is so distinct,
there’s no mistaking it for anything else.
It’s passable when Bond is relaxing on a
beach, but as MI6 tries to figure out their
next course of action, the beer sticks out
like a sore thumb.
The Internship
Google didn’t fund this Owen Wilson and
Vince Vaughn vehicle, but you’d be forgiven
if you thought they did.
The entire movie acts as free advertising
for the company, constantly discussing just
how awesome Google is at everything.
Google even got in on the creative process,
aiding with the script and scratching a scene
in which one of their self-driving cars crashes.
It came across as too self-congratulatory,
and the overall message didn’t mesh well
with the brand of comedy Wilson and Vaughn
broke in with in Wedding Crashers.
Many just saw it as one long advertisement,
and the film flopped upon its release.
Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice
Zack Snyder attempted to right the wrongs
of Man of Steel’s ending by retconning it
from Bruce Wayne’s perspective in Batman
V Superman.
The Gotham billionaire watches in horror as
aliens destroy his buildings, and he speeds
in a vehicle to get his co-workers to safety.
His car of choice is the all-new Jeep Renegade,
but there’s a slight problem.
The film’s opening sequence is supposed
to be set in 2013, when Man of Steel was released.
But this particular Jeep didn’t come out
until 2016.
Bruce was driving a car that wasn’t built
yet.
Mr. Wayne has all kinds of toys, but even
this is a bit much for him.
Speaking of great superhero show downs, our
friends over at the CBR Youtube channel just
posted a new video all about the All time
Best Superhero Rivalries from Marvel and DC.
Click here to check it out and be sure to
check out all the other awesome videos on
their channel.
From Deadpool Easter eggs to Game Of Thrones
secrets, these guys are killing it.
Click here or check out the link in the description
of this video and you will be in for a treat!
Those are our picks for the most egregious
instances of product placement in movies.
Are there any we missed?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!